teame
日本の歯医者
第4しょんん
僕がスカイスリーパーに座った瞬間お姉さんが1人部屋に入ってきて今から歯を磨き
ますがよろしいですかと聞いてくる
大丈夫です僕が答えるとお姉さんはその前に下半身の緊張をほぐす必要がありますので
といながらトランスフォーマーからローションを取り出してたっぷり手に付け
そして僕のベルト8
テオのろせません今でも聞かなかったことにしてください口を開けていただけますか
僕がゆきちゃんと町フェチの緑の段々畑を一緒に登っていると
益子した男性が診察室に入ってきて2なりに椅子を引き寄せて座り
そういったあ虫歯があるみたいですね
この奥歯磨きにくいんですよねはい
医者の言葉に頷くともなく頷いていると
また bravia に吸い込まれる段々畑の上の方から褐色の肌をしたぺる人女性が
降りてきてくれてすみませんマリアですと挨拶すると
町ピッチについて色々と説明してくれた話しながら彼女は風が吹くたびに中指で長い
茶色い髪
耳の後ろに書き上げたゆきちゃんは僕の脇を積ん2してなんか
シャンプーの cm のっぽくないと小声で言ってもらった
じゃあ今から詰めますね痛かったらマリアはそれでは今から山頂に迎えますがその前に
町内についてのご質問などはありますか
ユウユキワインカ人は車輪を使わずに待ちピッチを作ったって聞いたことありますが
本当ですかと聞く
マリアは得意げに微笑みそうですと答えた
はい終わりました車輪を使わずにこんな山の上に街を作るなんて本当にすごいですね
道元さん
東元さん消えてますかはいマリアの唇から歯医者の顔に視線を移す僕もう終わりました
よ道元さん
廃車を慣れた手つきでマスク外し道元さん随分我慢強いですねこれからは多くばにも気
をつけてくださいねと笑って言った
後ろに立っていたお姉さん僕を見て運行した
me
右かの背もたれを倒したままねー
っていうより普通に壊れた運転席によくになると壁から漏れてくる電動ドリルの音や人
の鳴き声を20分ほど聞かされるこれも拷問の一つなんだろうか
やがてドアの開く音がし
に3秒して閉まる音がするがその後は何も音がしない
気になって体を起こして部屋を見回すと
誰もいないじゃないかぞっとしつつ店周りを気にしながら
再びミニカいい椅子に横たわるもう20分ノイズ拷問に耐えると
またドアが開き
今度は禿げ上がったほ人が部屋に入ってくる5月の双眼鏡が付いたメガネみたいなもの
をかけていて全身からいかにもホビットらしいきつい体臭を漂わせている
彼は僕のつなりまでやってきていきなり声を上げた
でっ
虫歯はですが虫歯ん
ねえぽ人は拷問道具のところに行って自分の小さくて毛深いてでそれらを撫で始めた
なぜ虫歯ができるか
わかるかねぇ
砂糖や食べ物ぽ人僕の答えには興味がなかった平らなよ僕はいがビクッとするのが
わかったこれがいわゆる
廃止の取り調べなのだ同件は
それは好きかねぇ
そう言いながらほ人は妖しく微笑み釣り針のついたボールペンを持ち上げてみせた
釣りは好きか
聞いてるんだかっとその時壁から漏れてくる悲鳴
好きです僕は震えながら答えてホビットはちらりと僕見てもらったならいい
彼は釣り針をテーブルに戻し今度は何か紫色の液体の入った注射器を持ち上げて見せた
もう一つ質問してもいいかねその質問にすでに怯えながらも
刻みに謎区北
東元さんは怠け者かねぇ
の巻物って言われれば
たまに歯磨き方はす僕が話終わらないうちに
ホビット駅ない注射針を僕の歯茎に突き立てた強烈ないために全身がこの針目に涙が
浮かんだ
さってと
詰めるかそう言うとホビットは大門道具のテーブルの下から削岩機としか表し方のない
ものを取り出して僕の椅子に足をかけるとボクの上にまたがり
そして錆びついた道具の先が僕の唇に当てたあーてするんだアヌーをつぶってミニカの
安っぽい仕掛けを握りしめ
ん
がんばれ忍耐は1管
me